Solve for x, and we have the
absolute value of 2x minus 5
is equal to 11.
Now, the big, I
guess, insight you
need to have whenever you
have an absolute value
equation like this
is just to remember,
if I have the
absolute value of a
is equal to 11, what
do we know about a?
That means that a is equal to
11, or what else could a be?
Well, it could be negative 11.
a could be equal to negative
11 because there's two possible
a's that are exactly
11 away from 0.
It could be positive 11 or
it could be negative 11.
That's the exact same logic you
apply in an equation like this.
If the absolute value of
2x minus 5 is equal to 11,
that means that the stuff
inside the absolute value sign
either equals 11 or the stuff
is equal to negative 11.
Because if this is equal to 11,
the absolute value of 11 is 11.
If this thing over here
is equal to negative 11,
when you take its
absolute value,
it'll still be equal to 11.
So let's write that down.
So 2x minus 5 could
be equal to 11 or 2x
minus 5 could be equal
to negative 11, right?
Because in either case, if
we took its absolute value,
you would get 11.
Now, let's just solve
each of these equations.
Over here, we can add 5 to
both sides of this equation.
We get 11 plus 5 is 16.
2x minus 5 plus 5 is just 2x.
2x is equal to 16.
Divide both sides by 2,
we get x is equal to 8.
Now, let's do this situation.
2x minus 5 is equal
to negative 11.
Let's add 5 to both
sides of this equation.
The left-hand side we just
get a 2x, the 5's cancel out.
2x is equal to negative 5
plus 11, that's negative 6,
and then we can divide
both sides by 2.
And we get x is
equal to negative 3.
So we've gotten two
solutions depending
on whether this thing
in here is either
equal to 11 or negative 11.
We got x could be equal to
8, in which case 2x minus 5
would be 11, or we have x is
equal to negative 3, in which
case 2x minus 5 is
equal to negative 11.
Let's verify it.
So if x is equal
to 8, let's show
that it satisfies this equation.
So we'd get 2 times 8 minus 5.
The absolute value of 2 times 8
minus 5 should be equal to 11.
2 times 8 is 16
minus 5 is 11, so we
have the absolute value of
11, should be equal to 11.
And we know that's true.
The absolute value of 11 is 11.
So it all works out.
Now, let's try it with x
is equal to negative 3.
We get the absolute value of
2 times negative 3 minus 5
should be equal to 11.
So what's 2 times negative 3?
2 times negative 3 is
negative 6 minus 5.
The absolute value of that
should be equal to 11.
Well, negative 6 minus
5 is negative 11.
So the absolute
value of negative 11
should be equal
to 11, and it is.
The absolute value
of negative 11 is 11.
So we get 11 is equal to 11.
So they both work.